and here's the thing you've got to make
a decision at some point all of you
listening I had to make the same
decision at some point philosophically
theologically practically mathematically
financially relationally is debt the way
to get stuff done his debt at the end of
the story ten years out 20 years out
five years out is debt really the most
efficient methodology and I'll tell you
100 percent of time the answer is no 100
percent of time it's an absolute fact it
never works like you think it's gonna
work ever you ever see those ads easy
payments you know those people are lying
you ran an easy payment I never had an
easy payment I had a hundred and three
dollar and forty three cent on Sharon's
engagement ring I paid $1,100 at a
jewelry store for 0.24 carats that's not
even a fourth of a carat
it didn't even get up to the fourth of a
carat this is known as a chip and I paid
a hundred a hundred and three dollars in
easy payments it was never an easy
payment on that ring every time I wrote
that check and this was old school they
carried the they carried the debt in the
store you went in the store physically
and paid the debt so old school it
didn't matter
didn't matter that hundred and three
have so much money I didn't know that
was so much more I can't believe I had
that payment gas was $1.00 twelve I'm
paying a hundred and three dollars and
forty three cents a month for a chip
there's no such
his easy payments folks the borrower is
slave to the lender and it never says
accept student loans that's not the next
verse in the Bible the next verse in the
Bible is not except in business the next
verse in the Bible is not and I know
it's not any of that
the rich rules over the poor and the
borrower is slave to the lender there's
not a caveat there's not a release
mechanism 100% of the time you're not
going to hell it's not a sin and it's
certainly not a Salvation issue but 100%
of time that debt is mentioned in the
scriptures it's a negative mention it's
a curse you're a fool
you're a slave every time it's mentioned
that's what it says
and I decided I didn't want to be a
cursed fool slave because I've been a
cursing fool slave one hundred and three
dollars and forty three cents a month
for a chip kind of redneck hillbilly
idiot was I she meant wearing my disco
clothes going into that jewelry store
and giving him my c-note plus three
dollars and forty three cents
never again never again hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]